>>VOICEOVER: From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
RUTH: When I lost my sight,
the only thing I had was
reading. And it was like therapy
to me.
JOY: BARD is this beautiful
web-based program for searching
for books and for the ability to
download them.
EDDIE: I just can't recommend
it enough. It's a free service.
It's amazing how much
you can get.
HERB: They'll list different
kinds of fiction, like
historical fiction, gothic
novels, popular fiction,
classical fiction.
EDDIE: Now, this next step with
BARD Mobile has just been a
tremendous innovation.
Smartphone technology has just
been a godsend.
MARY: It's actually very simple.
You open the app and
it's completely accessible with
voiceover and magnification and
all of that.
RUTH: I can just independently
go and choose the books,
download it, and start reading.
MELANIE: I generally have a
cell phone with me, so to me
it's really nice to be able to
have the books on my phone.
TERIANA: I'm a big reader, but
I don't sit still. I'd rather
take the book with me and read
it when I'm going somewhere.
RUTH: BARD Mobile is one of
the best things that the library
could have ever done.
NARRATOR: Visit
loc.gov/ThatAllMayRead or call
1-888-NLS-READ to learn more
about theLibrary of
CongressBraille and Audio
Reading Download web-based
service andBARD Mobileapp.
Apply for NLS today.
VOICEOVER: This has been a
presentation of the Library of
Congress. Visit us at loc.gov.